signori sono l'unica persona con finta
nella vita quando e venerdì 13 oggi
venerdì 13 io quando c'era di 13 faccio
venerdì 16 con questo jason e vediamo se
compaiono la maschera mezza blu spero di
no perché a questo punto sarebbe
bruttissimo perché gli altri sun giocare
sono nella cacca io mi sa che non sono
io
meno male gli ha girato la testa ma
veramente sono dalla sapevo neanche si
potesse fare ma bene veri 13 signore il
gioco family friendly
spero di avere almeno culo nelle cose
che trovi in giro almeno quello perché
in genere non c'è uno che sta arrivando
poi subito e non vai lontano non voglio
amici
oggi questo bevitrici deve essere
vittorioso per me porca vacca almeno una
volta nella vita comunque vediamo come
la mappa ancorano vista la tanica l'han
trovata quindi manca la batteria solo
wow
vediamo se scatola baleno le chiavi la
batteria le chiavi le chiavi secondo me
sono un pelo più semplice la batteria la
vedo più difficile sento kiki affatichi
nata non è un tiki taka non è un
buonissimo segno però va bene intanto
esco c'è dovrei sentire gli altri non
sento né gli altri nenè riesco a parlare
io quindi che casino
la batteria io vado in queste case qua
ragazzi perché tanto c'è un sacco di
gente laggiù quindi meglio almeno non
sono da solo e teoricamente se qualcuno
riesce a trovar st maledetta batteria
magari potremmo farcela prova a vedere
qua dentro
l'importante è trovare le chiavi almeno
quelle quello sta cercando di far
partire la barca ma ce l'hai le chiedo
che cosa per fare partita bar cosa fate
un bravo che metti la tanica bravo bravo
lo zio
cosa manca devo capire cosa manca ciao
ragazzi cosa manca qua bravo che c'è il
flare in mano a lei li caveri che
introvabile regala quali stanno lassù
secondo me jason è lì sopra ragazzi
forcole monia sento casino tu lì a porta
hanno già sfondato a minchia figurati
già sfondata la porta la ragazza si può
trovare in tutto sto casino come questo
è una padella niente perché ha sentito
rumori ma non vedo jason quindi ottimo
chiavi chiavi nel cassetto
niente che viene cassetto che sto casino
non lo vedo jason non lo so lo sento e
basta dove gesù
il bordello qua mi sento di chi l'ha
manate cosa che hai detto
c'è uno nudo c'è uno nudo che corre
credo sia qui sotto minchia che bordello
non so neanche cosa stia succedendo per
meno male tutto questo non c'è un app e
una ventola che sia una maledizione
noi potrebbe essere ovunque la ventola
rega non ho idea che mi ha salutato la
l'ottavo piano aiuto che male mi sono
fatto malissimo aia mi sono buttato a
millesimo piano aiuto aiutami amico mio
aiuto aiuto a miss aperto stand aiutami
spara a fuoco e cosa ti aveva centrato
alta jason ai ha nominato io sono nato
ha stordito sono stato fortissimo dammi
una mano sono praticamente morto in
tutto sto casino per avere aiuto sono
vicino alla fattoria deprima aia ha
mancato picchia lo picchia lo sono morte
censurata anche la morte tra l'altro che
non si è vista una fatto solo è male
ragazzi siamo in un'altra partita spero
più decente ricordate prima perché
sporco del demonio
ecco la partenza la partenza è buona
promettere a sono io no mi sa che sono
io
porca vacca non volevo fare jason oggi
volevo fare tutto tranne quello forse
non è detto non lo sono io scherzavo
c'era il mio stesso acceso ma non sono
io meno male perché non c'è oggi oggi no
qua c'è la macchina lo ragazzi sono
state nel posto migliore però anche il
peggiore perché adesso arriverà
procedono sicuro sono entrati una porta
senza entrare nella porta ragazzi
servono batterie e taniche cose belle
cabau forse mi nascondo qui tanto questo
ultimo nascondiglio
l'ho trovato subito la vistola flare che
veramente ottima
se trovo in giro taniche o robe lafico
direttamente nella macchina ragazzi
bravi ha acceso
vai di su basi su dividiamoci destra e
della sinistra
ok ma volevo fare il figo e mirare in
entrata non sa fare neanche quello
chiavi nicchia una volta che apro un
cassetto trovò le chiavi subito esiste
lo richiami sono le cose più introvabili
del mondo dopo la ventola kamoun niente
le op le porte decide di non aprirla e
oggi ha preso la metà e zia devi trovare
le chiamate in tutto sto casino non sia
ancora trasportato la macchina che
strano maria io esco vediamo cosa
troviamo fuori niente
raga dobbiamo trovare qualcosa c'è
qualcosa in giro per forza ragazzi di
via vai a destra tu a me fa niente vado
io chi è quel periodo più ha chiuso la
porta poi fate i seri
c'è chi ha chiuso la porta e poi uscito
ad un genio un genio cacciavite photos
casinò ma sarebbe troppo filo chiarit
marco del demonio sono creduto per un
attimo
mai una volta che vicino ci sono le cose
che poi non ho ancora che dopo tutti
questi anni perché ormai c'è da almeno
quattro anni dopo tutti questi anni vg
ragazzi e ancora non ho capito
ve lo giuro se e ogni mappa per forza
spalmano le taniche le cose perché non è
mica detto sai che siccome non stonano
in tutte le mappe
ho sentito un casino un rumore che è
successo fa fusibile che non serva una
sega però fai da te c'è una [ __ ] tedesco
a trovare le chiavi qua dentro buono
questo questo è buono aprendo petardi
per distrarre jason ragazzi comunque
un'ascia bella queste fortissima se la
prendi la zia lo andata la zia di fianco
non c'è una tanica non c'è una batte
niente non c'è niente non c'è niente in
sto gioco niente
l'altra un'altra pistola pedardi
pazzesco pieno pieno di pistola tardi
non mi servono sono già un anno trovate
altre due mi dai una batteria un sa
qualcosa un qualsiasi cosa non devono
ora che ci avvolge niente poi altri
vincola certo io non trovo 8.000
cassetti intro le chiavi ma almeno una
tag una delle tre cose neanche una
simica questo è utilissimo sono le vado
rimettere no lavori mette la pozione
possibile che non mi serve una sega ha
capito tanto il fusibile non lo uso ok
perfetto meno se mi colpisce
ecco la batteria l'ho trovata rai che ho
trovato la batteria ottimo ora chiavi
non madonna c'ero quasi timi che le
trovo dai che ci sono 1.600 cassetti
forza porca quale quanti cassetti
esistono uno dico uno di questi che
abbia la chiav 1 non ci credo mi sono
incastrato no vabbè dai il suo gioco
proprio ma veramente io mi sono
incastrato porco the ok poi schiavi no
il contenuto svizzero per attenzione mi
serve lo prendo potevo svizzere
utilissimo attenzione ma dai 26
radioline le chiavi ti prego non trovo
le chiavi infattibile poi c'è un morto
né dalla roba non lo guardo sono il mio
personaggio diventa stupido
c'è anche un kit per recuperare vitali e
attenzione sono morti tutti fuggito e
hanno lasciato questi pezzenti ma
veramente io che sto facendo questa voce
quando le chiavi tutto da solo e niente
voi sono fuggiti porco demonio sono
stupido e non anche guardato la
situazione in genere semiassi in due
sono più di uno e morto gli altri sono
fuggiti ma che pirla niente lega pro
affinché alla batteria che vedevo dire
non c'è niente non ce le chiavi non c'è
la tanica non c'è nulla però provo ecco
l'haka un coltellino coltellino a
maledizione che male sono fatto
malissimo
va beh posso fare questa breve io questa
questa precisazione io ho cercato per
due ore la batteria e le chiavi niente
da solo quelli sono riusciti a liberarsi
capitolo a fuggire
madonna lo spartito faccia lo zio sei
incazzato mi da quelli nel mentre sono
riusciti a fuggire è capito a fuggire e
nel mentre io ho trovato la batteria
dopo due ore e finalmente e porca vacca
nonostante questo non son riuscito a
fare nulla cioè quelli dai in quattro
sono riusciti a fuggire io da solo no
ma ora mancato ai aperti così per te
allora ma ci fatto per la donna è anche
bravo piromane
mi sa che sei incazzato aiuto e ho
trovato gesù un incasso ragazzi non
pensavo di farli così male all autostima
va beh forse sei preso a calci da uno
questi capelli potrebbe avere un
effettivamente una botta di autostima
però sto morendo bravo chiudi la porta
che con casinò messo vicino allo schalke
con me però io mi frega niente
nell'altro e gli sta dietro
l'hack è male giulia porta ma chiuso
cenai uno dietro non te ne frega niente
di lui aiuto fammi entrare ma che c è in
testa di culo ma dai non ha fatto
entrare o pirla se mio compagno emenalo
vabbè sto vedendo scene incredibili in
tutto questo iscriviti al canale
schiacciate il tasto mi piace sotto il
video era come sempre ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo
bella ragazza
[Musica]